alors aujourd'hui on va mais défoncé sa
race mes vrais gens vraiment quoi à une
grosse grosse grosse idée reçue en vidéo
mais on va lui ont valu mettre bien mais
comme d'hab toi même tu sais ce sera
juste après l'intro
[Musique]
et salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mme encore je
suis ravie comme à chaque vidéo de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle vidéo
justement
et puis d'ailleurs si vous êtes
intéressé par la vidéo par les caméras
par le tournage par le montage tout ça
mais c'est le moment de vous poser la
question de est-ce que je vais cliquer
ou pas sur le petit bouton s'abonner
tout ça parce que probablement il y aura
des choses très intéressantes pour vous
sur cette chaîne du club
voilà je vous laisse y réfléchir le
temps de la vidéo ou même maintenant
vous pouvez cliquer aujourd'hui on va
donc démonter une très grosse idée reçue
en vidéo c'est quelque chose qui revient
très souvent c'est quelque chose qui est
mal compris donc on va essayé de
l'expliquer clairement simplement et de
voir un petit peu tous les points
positifs point négatif avant de se faire
une idée l'entendue on va pas rester sur
quelque chose d'hyper catégorique on est
des gens ouverts sur cette chaîne
on réfléchit on voit là on fait des
trucs intelligemment et cette grosse
idées reçues et bien c'est tout simple
c'est la règle des 180 degrés
d'obturation alors rien à voir avec la
règle des 180 degrés en composition ça
c'est complètement autre chose je vous
mets des liens dans la description pour
vous expliquer un petit peu tous que
c'est la règle des 180 degrés en
obturation vous n'en avez très
probablement entendu parler c'est cette
règle qui voudraient je dis bien
voudrais au conditionnel reste et bien
jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo parce que
c'est intéressant d'avoir la chose dans
son ensemble cette règle qui voudrait
que si on filme à une certaine cadence
d'image un nombre d'image par seconde
il faudrait systématiquement adaptés de
manière complètement arrêtée et sans
aucune autre alternative la vitesse
d'obturation alors je suis sûr y en a
déjà qui sont perdus ne vous inquiétez
pas on va ré expliquer toutes les bases
vous allez voir c'est très très
important que tout ce qu'on va dire ici
que petit à petit on va démonter les
idées reçues et on va voir ce qu'il faut
faire ou ce qu'il faut pas faire la base
de la vidéo c'est un gros mensonge bien
évidemment puisque les images que vous
ne captez en soi ne bouge pas la vidéo
c'est une succession d'imagés fixes une
succession de photos tout simplement et
vu qu'il y en a beaucoup
à la seconde
autre oeil ne fait pas la différence
entre une image fixe et une image en
mouvement
on a donc une illusion d'optique en fait
qui crée ce fameux mouvement vos
boîtiers vous propose d'enregistrer à
différentes cadence d'image c'est à dire
qu'il va vous de proposer d'enregistrer
à 25 images par seconde à 30 images par
secondes 60 à 100 à 120 problème encore
plus sains dans l'est jusqu'à plusieurs
milliers d' images par seconde sur
certaines caméras et on se pose souvent
la question de à combien d'image par
seconde
est-ce que je dois filmer art
généralement quand on regarde un film au
cinéma il est tourné à 24 ou 25 images
par seconde en fonction de la zone
géographique
ce n'est pas une règle absolue puisqu'il
existe des films qui ont été tournés à
d'autres cadence d'image men entendues
mais la plupart du temps on utilise
cette cadence
c'est pour ça que je vous recommande
souvent de créer vos projets je parle
bien du montage un pad du moment où on
va filmer à 25 images par seconde parce
que c'est un standard que l'oeil va
reconnaître auquel il est habitué parce
que monter à 25 images par seconde et
tourné à 25 images par seconde ce n'est
pas du tout la même chose pourquoi est
ce qu'on voudrait donc filmé à plus de
25 images par secondes puisque on va
monter à 25 images par seconde et bien
tout simplement parce que plus on a des
images par seconde plus on va pouvoir
créer des ralentis plus ou moins ralenti
plus il y as d'image plus on va pouvoir
ralentir la séquence peut aussi monter à
50 images par seconde ou plus mais c'est
une histoire de goût moi personnellement
je trouve ça vraiment pas jolie et pas
esthétique mais c'est une histoire de
ces maintenant car il est notre règle
des 180 degrés cette règle a dit que si
on filme à 25 images par seconde on doit
avoir une vitesse d'obturation qui va
être de 1 50e
on va multiplier le numérateur de la
fraction part de la vitesse d'obturation
c'est le temps que va mettre le capteur
pour prendre la lumière pour une image
que vous avez fini
alors il ya plein d'explications en
termes d'optique et de physique pourquoi
cette règle à qui a tout à fait lieu
d'être et d'où elle vient surtout donc
je vous mets des liens dans la
description il ya des chaînes qui ont
expliqué ça de manière hyper simple et
hyper efficace je vais pas revenir
dessus
et donc si on applique cette règle oslo
mots par exemple on a bastion film à 100
images par secondes une vitesse
d'obturation qui va être à un 200e ça
vous l'avez entendu par tous les
américains les canadiens les mackinnon
les machins il
pas de vous rabattre les oreilles avec
ça et moi je suis pas d'accord du tout
avec le fait qu'il faille appliqué
systématiquement et de façon
complètement borné cette règle là à
toutes vos vidéos pourquoi ces
conseillers parce que tout simplement en
suivant cette règle du moins 1 1 50e on
obtient un flou de mouvement un flou de
bougé qui va être proche du fou naturel
observé parlait mais ce qu'on oublie
souvent de vous dire c'est que ce flou
de bougé il est intéressant dans
certains cas mais pas dans d'autres
autrement dit si vous filmer une scène
d'action par exemple où il ya des
mouvements qui vont très vite si vous
filmez 1/50 bas vous allez rien à voir
mais rien du tout ça va aller beaucoup
trop vite et il y aura beaucoup trop de
fou cette règle elle est vraiment
utilisable dans certains cas notamment
des cas où l'environnement
il est optimale c'est à dire qu'on va
avoir le contrôle sur la lumière on va
avoir une équipe éventuellement qui va
pouvoir gérer les choses on va on va pas
être tout seul à filmer quelque chose de
complètement run and gun ou à faire du
reportage c'est juste pas possible de
faire ça en permanence je ne dis pas
qu'il ne faut pas le faire mais je dis
que vouloir le faire et vouloir
respecter cette règle en permanence pour
des vidéastes comme vous et moi qui
faisons du reportage du run and gun de
l'événementiel c'est aller au casse-pipe
direct il ya un autre truc qui est lié à
ça c'est le slogan la vitesse
d'obturation quand on filme à 120 images
par seconde par exemple c'est là où
plein de gens font l'erreur
le 1 2 centièmes c'est à utiliser quand
on est sûr de la lumière artificielle
par exemple on va se fixer à 1 200e pour
ne pas avoir un effet de flickr ring
vous pourrez faire le test chez vous si
vous mettez une vitesse d'obturation un
petit peu bizarre avec des lumières
artificielles avec des ampoules vous
aurez un une espèce de sentiment qui
sera très disgracieux et l'idée c'est de
ne pas descendre en dessous de 1 200e
puisque en dessous bien au raz du flou
de mouvement et si on filme à son image
par seconde
c'est pour faire du ralenti c'est pour
avoir un mouvement fluide sans flou et
bien-être et donc par conséquent on ne
veut pas ce flou de mouvement sur du
ralenti donc ce 1 2 centièmes à son
image par seulement nous c'est un
centième à 50 images par seconde l'idée
c'est de ne les pas descendre en dessous
et de s'y coller quand on a une lumière
artificielle
mais dans tous les cas à un 200e et là
c'est physique on n'aura pas de flou de
mouvement à moins que le mouvement ait
très très très très très très vite mais
il y en aura pas même si on
à filmer à 5 images par seconde et un
200e et ben si on ramène ça à 25 images
par seconde le flou de mouvement
il est plus là c'est mort c'est un 200e
n'y a pas de mouvement ça veut donc dire
aussi que il ya une histoire de filtres
ndé dans l'histoire on vous a peut-être
aussi beaucoup parlé des filtres end et
qu' il faut les mettre pour pouvoir
respecter la règle dans tient une forte
luminosité etc
le filtre n'diaye on a déjà parlé dans
une vidéo qui s'affiche quelque part là
c'est tout simplement une espèce de
lunettes de soleil en fait pour votre
objectif pour enlever un petit peu de
lumière quand il y en a trop c'est tout
à fait valable si on filme un sujet qui
n'est pas vraiment en action en
extérieur le 1 50e va être vraiment
indiqué à 25 images par seconde il
faudra par conséquent un filtre inde et
puisqu'on aura beaucoup trop de lumière
encore que si on filme un match de foot
ou des choses comme ça là encore on peut
augmenter le chanteur puisqu'on ne veut
pas de flou de mouvement bien entendu
mais en solo mots c'est là que ça
devient complètement con ne m'étais pas
un filtre ndé si vous filmez du slow mot
augmenter votre vitesse d'obturation
puisque de toute façon vous n'aurez pas
de flou de mouvement à moins d'avoir
vraiment une lumière extraordinaire
pouvait gérer ça avec l'obturation avec
le moi ça m'arrive de monter à 1 1000e
et honnêtement il n'y a aucune
différence à l'oeil du moins entre un
200e et un millième enfin vraiment il
faut vraiment aller chercher à chercher
ou avoir des sujets qui bouge très très
vite pour voir la différence voilà le
film trendence l'homo ça n'a aucune
utilité vraiment vraiment aucune utilité
pause café pause café parce que la neige
m'emballe là je m'emballe un type
effectivement à un 50e en plein après
midi si on veut garder un petit peu de
flou d'arrière-plan et pas avoir une
ouverture tout riquiqui pas forcément on
va mettre un filtre ndé et je suis pas
en train de dire que les filtres end et
ne servent à rien j'en ai toujours dans
mon sac au cas où et je m'en sers je les
utilise mais je les utilise pas hyper
souvent parce que ce que je fais ne s'y
prête pas forcément
donc pour résumer cette règle elle est
très intéressante elle est importante à
connaître mais il faut aussi être
intelligent quant à son utilisation
les choses qu'il faut retenir le filtre
end et déjà vous allez vous en servir
uniquement si vous filmez à 25 images
par seconde et dans des conditions très
forte de lumière et 6
le film est pas quelque chose qui va
très vite et si vous avez envie d'avoir
ce fou de mouvement donc ça fait
beaucoup de conditions pour l'utiliser
plutôt que de se dire il faut cesser un
super outil dans il va demander des cas
spécifiques dans lesquels ça a un
intérêt et c'en est vraiment ensuite la
règle des 180 degrés ce fameux shooter à
1 50e à 25 images par seconde vous allez
utiliser dans un environnement contrôlé
avec une lumière contrôler et à
condition que vous vouliez encore une
fois ce flou de mouvement et enfin la
dernière chose à retenir c'est que si
vous faites des ralentis si vous faites
du slow mots le filtre end et on oublie
ça ne sert à rien et la règle des 180
degrés au ralenti on va faire du tout
pile entre guillemets quand on est en
lumière artificielle pour éviter le
flickr et on évitera de descendre en
dessous de 1 200e pour essayer de pas
avoir justement de flou de mouvement et
en cas de forte lumière pour baisser
l'exposition on pourra augmenter la
vitesse d'obturation autant qu'on veut
et voilà on a démonté une idée reçue
qu'on entende partout
merci peter mc kinnon d'avoir fait faire
cette erreur à tout le monde d'avoir mis
un petit peu le bordel dans le cerveau
des gens en disant ah c'est la règle il
faut absolument un lagarde est pourquoi
je france 3 c'est tout pourri c'est une
chose que j'ai souvent en vidéo vous
êtes dans un domaine artistique
l'important ça va être l'intention les
règles elles sont là pour vous donner
des guides elles sont là pour vous
donner des indications mais quand vous
les connaissez et surtout quand vous les
comprenez vous pouvez vous en affranchir
vous pouvez aller au delà des règles
pour faire le rendu que vous voulez le
rendu que vous avez décidé que vous
aurez dans votre vidéo flou de mouvement
pas flou de mouvement
voilà ça c'est après votre choix mais il
faut comprendre la règle avant de
l'appliquer parce que là pour le coup il
ya énormément de gens qui applique cette
règle sans la comprendre et qui se
complique la vie monumentalement alors
qu'il n'y a pas besoin
voilà c'est donc tout pour moi
aujourd'hui j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aura plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas à mettre le traditionnel coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo
dites moi dans les commentaires si vous
avez appliqué cette règle et si ce n'est
pas déjà fait vous pouvez bien entendu
cliquer sur le petit bouton s'abonner
qui se situe juste en dessous lui aussi
sur la cloche également pour être
notifié dès qu'une nous
vidéo sort et puis moi je vous dis comme
d'habitude les amis reste est curieux et
à très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
j'ai reçu une tondeuse pour la barbe et
je me dis que vu que la situation va
encore un petit peu continuer je me tâte
quand même à mettre un gros coup de
tondeuse au dessus mais j'ai peur de
vous faire peur je sais pas si pas ce
que vous en dites moi j'ai quand même
toujours rêvé de
ça va avoir un petit côté satisfaisant
qui est pas qui est pas dégueu là on
verra on verra se donnent rendez vous à
la prochaine vidéo peut-être que j'aurai
une casquette
voilà